o primeiro produto fã do mundo
foi essa liberdade isso foi em 1884
quando a frança do estatuto dos estados
unidos
a cidade de nova york foi escolhida para
sediar o momento porém ela não tinha os
recursos necessários para construir a
estrutura da ilha e da base da etapa foi
quando joseph pulitzer que hoje é mais
conhecido pelo prêmio mundial de
jornalismo gravar seu nome decidiu fazer
uma campanha em seus dois jamais que
circulavam na região de nova york nessa
campanha ele pediu à população que
doasse um ou cinco dólares para
financiar o projeto
em um ano eles arrecadaram os mais de
100 mil dólares necessários para
construir a estrutura
aposto que todos vocês a tia já fizeram
algum tipo de crowdfunding um português
na investir é financiamento coletivo ou
também popularmente conhecido como
vaquinha o meu primeiro pan ning com a
minha mesada provavelmente foi um entre
dois litros
depois do jogo de futebol com os colegas
nessa época eu morava na argentina a
moral dos 8 aos 18 na argentina então
cada um de nós o fulhan o gabriel o pato
o martim e os dois ruas
dávamos 50 centavos pra comprar o nosso
refri
depois do jogo
mas eu crescia e comecei a me interessar
pelo mercado de financeiro mais
precisamente pelas ofertas públicas de
investimento e descobrir que essas
ofertas públicas de investimento não são
muito diferentes da vaquinha do re frio
ou da história da estátua da liberdade
mas elas incluem um monte de
intermediários por exemplo para que uma
simples captação de recursos de uma
empresa como mercado para desenvolver um
novo projeto essa empresa vai precisar
contratar uma bolsa de valores ou no
mercado de balcão organizado um custo
diante um escritor adora uma agência
classificadora de rating um agente
fiduciário e um banco diante esses nomes
são bem complexos e não dizem nada o que
eles fazem de fato não é nada muito de
muito extraordinário e fazendo uma
analogia com a compra de dois litros
é como se eu precisasse a falar com o
diretório chamar o guardinha da escola o
professor de educação física escolher
qual dos meus colegas iria arrecadar o
dinheiro e só ele poderia arrecadar o
dinheiro que os demais
e depois qual dos meus colegas quando
todo mundo tivesse dentro do bar
enquanto não tivesse dentro do bar iria
pegar o dinheiro daquele que arrecadou e
aí sim finalmente trocar o dinheiro pelo
referir com a dona do bar provando em
surgiu para eliminar intermediários
financiar projetos e fazer com que as
pessoas se sintam parte daquele projecto
que elas estão financiando afinal de
contas se estar financiando algo que é
muito com aquilo aconteça
alguns exemplos de crowdfunding de
doação são por exemplo
a banda teatro mágico que captou 250 mil
reais para financiar o seu cd sua turnê
e dessa maneira eles conseguiram
eliminar o selo musical que antes era o
único que decide dia qual banda iria
gravar ou não um cd passando passando
pelo relógio pé bom que é o primeiro
esmalte do mundo inclusive um dos
primeiros projetos a captar mais de um
milhão de dólares via para o flamengo
o pego tirou da indústria o poder de
decidir quais produtos estariam na
prateleira das lojas mas o profano em
também pode servir como uma simples
vaquinha para algo mais inusitado como
por exemplo uma praia à praia de alvor
ou a que fica na ilha sul da nova
zelândia
a história é bacana então vou contar um
pouquinho mais é essa ilha era uma ilha
particular e o dono deixava qualquer um
freqüentasse as suas as praias como
vocês podem ver elas são bem para dizer
né
só que nesse ano em 2016 o dono decidiu
se desfazer da propriedade e colocou à
venda
foi quando os banhistas começaram a se
perguntar se o próximo dono continuaria
permitindo que qualquer um usufruto da
ilha e das suas praias
então dois os seus banheiros mais
freqüentes decidiram fazer uma campanha
de pronto pra mim arrecadaram 1 milhão e
700 mil dólares
compraram a ilha e adoram um parque
nacional
dessa maneira as suas praias
permaneceram públicas pra sempre mas o
contrário também pode ser polêmico como
é o caso do óculos gift que é um óculos
de realidade virtual que está
revolucionando o mundo dos games e até
da medicina
o óculos geek capitão 2 milhões de
dólares em sua campanha em prol do
flamengo ea polêmica surgiu quando o
produto foi entregue quando ele ficou
pronto
a empresa foi adquirida pelo facebook
por um bilhão de dólares
alguns
há participantes algumas pessoas que
doaram recursos para viabilizar esse
produto se sentiu no direito de ter uma
participação sobre a venda da empresa
mas isso não aconteceu porque era um fã
de doação lembrou as intermediárias que
eu comentei pra vocês
eles existem e são pesados e trazer
muita burocracia do processo burocracia
geralmente implica em aumento de custos
tão facilmente ter aqueles players que
eu mencionei antes supera os 500 mil
reais o custo e conseqüentemente as
ofertas precisam ser bem grande porque a
gente precisa diluir esse custo no no
valor da oferta para que faça sentido e
o pior de tudo essas ofertas por serem
muito grandes
geralmente são oferecidas somente a
fundos de investimento e grandes
investidores ea grande parte da
população não fica sabendo disso e perde
excelentes oportunidades assim como o
crowdfunding de doação existe outro tipo
outra modalidade que visa eliminar
intermediários que é o próprio investe
também conhecido como eco team
crowdfunding ou em português de
investimento coletivo no ano passado
investe em vez de ser uma doação em
troca de um produto ou de um brinde tu
investe em torno de um retorno um
trabalho de retorno financeiro e aqueles
intermediários que eu citei
muitos deles foram criados para evitar
que o investidor foi enganado mas as
novas ferramentas de internet vêm
aumentando o nível de confiança entre as
pessoas porque as informações estão cada
vez mais públicas tão facilmente
consegue verificar como aquela pessoa se
comportou em outra ocasião como que ela
desenvolva
deu aquele contrato que foi combinado e
dessa maneira facilmente tu consegue
decidir se tu vai ou não fazer um novo
negócio aquela pessoa
os modelos tradicionais que estão
perdendo a o estão caindo em desuso neto
deixando de ser usados incentivam
exatamente o oposto
eles incentivam é que tu não cumpra o
que combinou porque as informações elas
são privadas poucas pessoas têm acesso
aquilo
utilizando-se desses mecanismos mais
modernos nas ferramentas que surgiram
ultimamente incorporadores vem
desenvolvendo projetos grandes e
pequenos inclusive já estão pequenos que
cabia naquele terreno baldio que tem
provavelmente perto da sua casa ou do
trabalho
nesse terreno geralmente ele era
esquecido ele é deixado de lado porque o
projeto que cabe nele não justifica os
valores que se precisa fazer até na
captação se precisa de valores muito
menores para desenvolver um projeto para
esse terreno mas nesse terreno e já tem
um monte de dinheiro investido tanto
pela nossa prefeitura quanto por outras
empresas porque nesse terreno já está
passando na frente uma rua canos de água
e esgoto fios de dados entre outros por
não estar sendo usadas de terreno
provavelmente a cidade está expandindo
para suas periferias como de uma maneira
maior ela não precisaria se desenvolver
tanto a gente poderia economizar um bom
dinheiro e além disso o impacto urbano
emdur seria muito grande e eu que
comecei fazendo o meu primeiro papel de
fã mim pra comprar um resfriado 2 litros
com os nossos colegas depois do jogo
futebol hoje ajudo grandes e pequenos
incorporadores mas principalmente
incorporadores e inovadores a
desenvolver projectos a captar recursos
para todos os tipos de itá e tamanho do
projeto mas principalmente a gente
permite que qualquer um possa participar
porque a gente entende que vários
pequenos investidores são muito mais
importantes para o processo do que um
grande investidor e as pessoas não
investem só pelo retorno financeiro
ela foi enganada também por apoiar algo
que elas acreditam algo que elas
gostariam de ver na sua cidade que elas
possam usufruir que elas possam como
viver e aproveitar daquilo
hoje o crowdfunding já vem viabilizando
os shows produtos praias
é difícil eu acredito que cada vez mais
ele vai moldar a cara da nossa cidade e
por que não até a nova estátua da
liberdade
obrigado
[Aplausos]